Casablanca look at all the white
buildings say thank you
shukran shukran shukran
we are finally in good morning
are you say good morning you know
something you so long
not miss hello no joy say thank you
chakra that 1gb remember babe it says
day 2 of Morocco this really only the
second day oh this is our third day of
being in Morocco because we got in 2
days ago but a day 2 of the tour and
we're gonna explore fess old town fess
Medina fess
[Music]
ya know we're at my pallet you're the
queen of a loop of this and you have a
palace in the factory guys just named us
hanging I forgot what our new job
[Music]
[Music]
you know they haven't had like a mini
miniature freak out in a long time
came out of me bringing that baby found
me on the trigger use it for the cat
felt it
it's a baby if you want listen if you
want this one to leave the big girl you
can be exactly the same
yeah we actually potable
divas you're also are assuming your kiss
right are we going out or over yeah now
the old Medina which means the old city
the city was built in 807 it's really
old the oldest city in the world that
has still been used by the same people
in the same building like it's never
been destroyed by fire earthquakes or
anything that's so amazing and he was
saying that he cuz he grew up there and
that he knows families that have been in
the same home for like 12 generations
that's insane doing away to construct
the walls is really smart because it's
clay later - the brick and stone and
wood and so anytime that there's a
committee earthquakes the wood absorbs
it which all the walls are still up
since April
Tate's I started building at 8:07 but
Kate away that's a lot history
cool we need to bloom this is my
favorite trip ever so far everything I'm
saying and everything I'm eating our
tour guy was telling us how a lot of
these streets if you're not from this
neighborhood are from the family you're
not really welcomed in these streets so
we're a granted that privilege of
walking through these streets right now
pretty cool this is where we get chased
by the guards are running through the
streets
I mean we were in syphilis not sure it's
like the most local weeks or possibly
gotten that's true
[Music]
now now we are in the marketplace
obsessed it's very crowded in here watch
oh I wish I knew as much Arabic as they
do English
[Applause]
oh my goodness I'm about to show you
something first ones if you don't want
to see you look right now that's wild
that's really wild we're just giving
this I feel like we're going to a club I
got a secret entrance to like a really
obscure club all right over in the
leather shop and it smells like leather
and manure it's good for that
[Music]
and that's now just intensified out here
no same one oh good to me little winner
was such as you don't mind the smell
that was making a rat video this would
be a dope rat scenario if I was making a
rat video yeah live here
our tour guide was same in order to be
accepted to this University you have to
memorize the entire crunch
[Music]
yeah well you'd like a pizza what is my
favorite dish here
[Music]
all right so Casey's in the shower we
just got some massages they were pretty
good in my opinion here at the hotel we
got the massages I just kind of liked
how though you were doing things that
haven't been done to me before I guess
if that makes sense I usually get
massages or likely douche massages or
like the Korean massages or the Chinese
massages but I've never gone in a
Moroccan massage so that was a different
experience and it was kind of
interesting too because you're
completely nude and they don't shy away
from any body parts other than you know
privates down there but yeah like she
was going all in everywhere and so yeah
and then after I got the traditional ha
ha mom it's like a type of bath that
they do and they rub like all this black
stuff all over them and guess it was
pretty interesting it was an experience
but now we're getting ready to go to
dinner cuz tonight we're gonna see some
belly dancing so I'm excited for that
alright we are now about to eat dinner
and not just any dinner what kind of
dinner yeah
this is a big truck I thought was just a
balcony but it's more cables another
thing we're doing today is we're having
Moroccan wine tonight just super excited
about that remember learning
Rosie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright baby we're heading to the Sahara
we're about to ride some camels later on
highlight the trick now we're gonna camp
in the desert where ever I know no clue
neither no we're just in this little
town in the middle of I don't know where
but I've been trying to go to sleep so
last night we went to sleep brilliantly
we got to face him Isaac which is nice
cuz it's been really hard to time it out
I said cuz he whenever we're at the
hotel we have Wi-Fi he's either at
school or sleeping and finally last
night we stayed up late enough to where
right when he got picked up from school
he was able to FaceTime us so we were
talking for a while and then we finished
packing
we left the hotel at 6:00 and we're
heading to the Sahara Desert so exciting
I'm just really tired excited it's get
excited you know it's crazy I keep
thinking about the camel head that I saw
at the market that was crazy
every time I think of a camel no I just
think of it ahead it's pretty bad
hopefully all get new memories [ __ ] em
yo everyone's stretching getting their
blood circulated at this pit stop this
is the highlight of the trip we're about
to get on our camel ride and then we're
gonna spend the night in the desert I'm
so excited
camels do smell a little bit though over
on the move
[Music]